Jojo rabbit was so good congratulations
guys
Jojo rabbit won the People's Choice
Awards at the tif Festival Toronto Film
Festival and marriage story getting so
much buzz are you ready to be the queen
of awards season no I'm ready to be at
all I get sounds very scary um no it's
uh it's been yes it's it's really been a
very exciting time with both of these
films at the Toronto Film Festival and
such different types of different movies
but really movies I think that have a
where the the the there's a similarity
in in the message at the phones both
carry which is that you know what you're
left with is is love and you know that
message seems to really resound with
with audiences and both of these films
have had a it's amazing to I've never
experienced such an impact that they
have on people you know they're really
left with a lot to process and it's it's
fantastic you know I'm happy that people
kind of connection to us and the
audience understood it more than the
preference what were your parents
reactions to being a part of a film like
this because first impression until you
watched it you have no idea what this
could be about I know this was your
first film so what was that like yeah oh
my mom cried when she saw a man hunting
Gil in uniform but ya know she did she
was I wake up this is terrifying but no
I think it was important to show the
story because I showed how ridiculous
and now hateful that war is and such sir
yeah and then my periods have been a
mess
and a mess of rollin in my career so far
and obviously because in my parents I
would be here without them but also
because they've just been incredibly
supportive so it was when I found out
that I got this role it was I was I was
beyond ecstatic and so were they so kind
of we were very excited together what
was Scarlett like as your mom and your
Savior so to speak with a mom figure in
this film you were great I'm speaking in
third persons really would know you
really made me feel kind of bold and not
less than and because your mother in
your chart actress that it kind of felt
like I wasn't but I felt kind of left
out in such an event waiting for like
what am i doing huh but you were very
professional though because women grew
up on at all yeah you were we're totally
professional he grew up you know around
on film sets both of his parents are you
know and different do different things
in the industry but you know I think it
was you had a lot of comfort around the
set more than a lot of other kids
wouldn't and you're such a natural actor
and he's such a lovable person and it
was very very easy to you know feel
maternal towards him because he's just a
little cutie pie and and Thomasin and I
you know we met in this very intimate
moment because the we really did all of
our acting in like a room that you
couldn't even just couldn't even like it
straighten up in you know though is very
like let's get it we both injured
ourselves in that shot I was like does
it
I noticed don't look like a crawl space
but like does it have to be across um
but you know might yeah she got cozy in
there
I lost I might go in and just have a bit
of a nap yeah it's uh but you know these
characters they don't actually really
know each other very well and they're
learning about one another in this
little intimate space and you know would
have been had I not been acting against
another actor that was so powerful and
soulful as Thomason wasn't so present
and available like that emotionally and
it probably would have been pretty
difficult but it was it was such a
absolute it was a easy easy thing and
they're you know they're connected to
one another through this experience that
feels very life or Japanese you know
really they're constantly on edge
together so they share a lot of the same
feelings about what's going on yeah and
and and scarlet and Rose I think for
ourselves that she was really really
missing her mum of course and I'm really
missing her a mother figure so having
scarlet or Rosie there and someone who
that who she's she's German about you
know Elsa should be scared of this woman
but she's a someone who's a savior and
in a mother figure and an outsider house
is kind of yearning for that so it was a
really special kind of yeah very
intimate space